hello everyone my name is Sharon Pope
I'm the head of marketing programs at Y
Combinator and is my pleasure to welcome
back to the stage ycs
partners coming up Catman y'all ik
Kirstie nephew
adora Polly Jessica and Carolyn I'm
gonna stand over here I'm gonna stand oh
it so just as a quick reminder as i
unlock my phone and please submit your
questions that slide Oh calm ASL I do
calm and the event code is FFC so you
can also upload questions so if you want
to kind of try to prioritize of what
questions get asked these are your
questions this is your time to ask all
right okay so first question will YC
ever open a New York City office Carolyn
oh no one to you you know what I think I
think that we never say never at Y
Combinator and as somebody mentioned
earlier I can't remember maybe it was
cat we experiment a lot so it could be
that in our future we have an
experimental NYC outpost or maybe in a
different city but I think that we'd
like to try things and see what works
and if it doesn't work we don't do it
again but it's always worth a try please
though don't like start any rumors or
get your hopes up this is just the point
is we never say never there are no plans
that's true there are no immediate plans
to do that
so yeah that's but yeah sorry there are
no weather one thing I'll add to that is
that I I meet a lot of founders all over
the world and at this point in time I
still think it's helpful for any founder
from anywhere to spend you know three
months in the Bay Area and get to build
that Network there's such so many
investors there so many other founders
and then you can you can stay there for
that amount of time and then
theoretically if this is where if New
York is where your customers are you
move back to New York
but at this point it is still so much
easier to raise and build that network
there so even spending a short amount of
time I think still helps so alright and
speaking of building our network one
popular question is I think a few people
have talked about finding people who are
10x people right so those people who you
hire and the people you surround
yourselves with that are just over the
top really great mentors and peers so
how do you go about building that
Network how do you find that and how did
you find the ones in your lives I will
throw that one to Jessica
how do you surround yourself how do you
how do you find fun the kind of
excellent people that will help cushion
board I mean I think I can think back to
what we did 13 years ago because by the
way we didn't know anyone in Silicon
Valley and we had to to meet people and
grow our network and I think if you're
working on something interesting then
people who are really good will
themselves be interested in it and if
you sort of genuinely want to talk to
people and get advice I mean most people
in Silicon Valley are pretty open to it
but I think just working on something
interesting and being insightful about
what you're working on makes for
fascinating conversation and people like
that yeah what about Holly maybe you
could answer also when it comes to
dealing about the founder uh well I'll
throw a fun story that a different YC
founder Eric makovski he was the founder
of pebble and he had he came from Canada
and most most people don't obviously
have a network in Silicon Valley and
that's why they joined YC that's why you
should join YC but he came down and he
was working on basically trying to fit
like an entire computer processor in
this little tiny little form factor and
the early early Apple computer like
computer designers were like writing
this blog and it was like a really nerdy
blog and he followed it and he sent out
a note to the founder and he's like yeah
I'll meet with you for coffee and I
think as Jessica said that there's a lot
of
of paying it forward culture
particularly in Silicon Valley which is
another reason why people do like to
have you come out there and it's weird
investors don't like jumping on a plane
there's a lot of things they don't
really and they'd like to meet you face
to face still in many ways if they so
it's it's really good for that so but
piggybacking off of Jessica in terms of
that definitely start finding people
that you look up to that are in the same
field and I think you can reach out to
them in terms of like hey you know I
want to ask if you can ask specific
questions that's actually very helpful
because on the other side in general I
think people are looking to help but if
they're just like hey do you want to
meet and just have coffee with me it's
really hard because you don't know on
that other side how busy they are and
it'd just be much though they'll be more
appreciative of it if they're like hey
these are the questions I'm looking to
answer and what your your background can
give to me and then obviously sometimes
you know you'd be surprised but there
are also things that you can give as
well like you are the expert in Marina
was expert in incense like there would
be nothing I would be able to tell her
around that and she could give me some
some interesting insights into that that
might be helpful for what I'm doing in
my business so don't just count yourself
either the one thing I'll add is you can
always just go work at a startup from
someone that you admire and work
directly with the founder and I think
that's that's a good way to get some
media time with somebody awesome also a
lot of people wondering about a hat tips
on how they can find a co-founder um
adora while you're talking do you want
to talk a little bit about that
micophone was my brother so that was
easy
easy was well I was gonna say one of the
things to be careful about is I get a
little nervous when people say how do I
find a co-founder because one of the
things that we stress is that you don't
actually go out and find one you
probably look within your own network
and the founder of relationship that you
form is probably more of an organic one
so college friends and old friends from
your prior life like people that you
know pretty well people that you're
close to tend to make the best founder
teams yeah usually it's someone you
spend a lot of time with in college or
at work I think those with
most common ones are a question of just
generally are there startups that YC
wants to fund more than others are there
areas that ycs extra interested in
female founded startups all right
there's also the requests for startups
page there where we list like hey we'd
love to see startups solve you know
diversity create a million jobs voice if
you don't have one in that area it
doesn't mean that we won't accept you
and even if you it's just these are
things that are interesting and we put a
call out for them and that's why
Combinator dot-com slash RFS and and
yeah I think some of the most
interesting ideas we fund are things we
wouldn't have thought of ourselves you
know I know when Airbnb came through
Jessica and Paul thought the idea was
crazy
right so we you know I think yeah Holly
was saying just because your ideas not
on that list doesn't mean we're not
interested in it I think also just no
idea is too crazy for us like we'd never
think an idea is like oh that's crazy
would never find that like we just don't
have that thought and Kirstie could you
answer is there a level of startup that
that YC isn't mostly looking at in terms
of stage so we think we can be helpful
to any startup up to Series A so that's
like a really big spectrum we have
companies who come to us with just an
idea we have companies who come to us
who are already generating revenue we
have companies who are already
profitable we have companies who have
raised maybe a million or two in seed
funding and because we work with each
company in a very specific manner to
them we help them with what they need we
can be helpful in all those stages and
so I think the important thing is let us
make the decision about who we want to
fund you know if you say oh I'm too
early for Y Combinator I'm not going to
apply you're not even giving us the
chance to see your company so apply you
have nothing to lose
and it means that the you know we can we
can see and we can we can apply our
expertise to see what could be amazing
about your company nothing any kind of
applied before please do apply again we
have like over 50% of the batch has
applied before I think of the numbers
like creeping up now I'm throwing out
nothing we heard from earlier sent
forgotten on our third try cat would you
answer just generally what YC is
thinking about what efforts wise he puts
forward to grow diversity within our
founder population this is something I'm
super interested in and you know we've
all had the pleasure of working on at YC
for female founders for example in this
batch of Y C so summer 2018
27 percent of the companies in the batch
have a female founder one of the one of
the challenges is only 23 percent of the
companies who applied had a female
founder so we want you know so we try to
do as much as we can to support female
founders even outside of the YC network
so we do female founders conference
hoping to connect with women who are
starting companies already or inspire
women who haven't started companies to
start them we do office hours with
female founders we also do office hours
with black and Latino founders to
encourage them to apply we during the
batch we connect the women in our
batches to female investors prior to
going out and raising money just so they
can get advice from women who've seen a
lot of founders come to them seen a lot
of female founders can give them advice
is there anything I'm missing and yeah
so so I think hopefully over the course
of the next few years we'll see that
number increase of women NYC and I think
out of Jessica on Jessica's slide I
think it's a total we funded how many
it's like three hundred fifty eight
women so far yeah it's great
umm fundraising questions so maybe
Kirsty grab the mic but anyone else to
chime in
just the question of when to raise like
how do you know when to raise whether
it's seed funding and then also maybe
thinking about that series a can I just
say one thing on this raise money when
you don't need it like that that's the
best time to but don't wait until you
only have like three months runway we
have believe it or not a lot of startups
that come to us and like we're running
out of money we have you know four
months in the bank and we're like what
you're going out to raise money with
only four months runway like it's just
creates disaster so sorry I've been
thinking about that lately so I wanted
to put that in go ahead so I think it
depends who you're raising from as well
usually the the first money that a
company will raise will be from
individuals who are who are who are
investors and at that stage when you're
talking to those people then it's
usually because they're either super
interested in the space that you're in
or you already know the people and they
know how amazing you are as a founder
and so at that stage it's easier
fundraising is never easy but it's
easier to raise on an idea that doesn't
necessarily have traction and growth as
you then progress and you're talking to
institutional investors so BC's some of
the largest seed funds that's the point
where you need to be able to show that
the people want what you're making and
by the way that you do that is that you
show that there is growth and users that
there's growth in revenue that your
churn is at a manageable level and
that's how you start to then paint the
story of this is how this company
becomes a billion-dollar company and so
depending depending on the stage that
you're at will depend on who you talk to
how you talk about your company and the
types of money that you you
it's also very it's very easy to fall
into the trap of raising too much money
if you're one of the lucky people that
have a relatively easy time fundraising
so also think about how much money do
you actually need to get to that next
milestone because when you get to that
next milestone and you're raising the
next amounts of money it's going to be
as a higher valuation in theory and so
you know the dilution that you're taking
as a as a founder will be less because
the the invest is putting money and it's
a higher valuation whereas if you raise
a bunch of money really early on that's
likely to be at a much lower valuation
so more dilution to you as a founder so
adora and Holly maybe for this one it's
a speaking of traction what are some
examples of what counts as traction for
a b2c company and the acknowledgement
that it varies by business just kind of
some principles that you might gauge
that's by consumer companies so mine is
a gaming company and it might be a
little unique in terms of traction
because it's usually very much like hits
driven so it's either a hit or it's not
and needs to get into the top ten but in
terms of early on when we were just
starting out in terms of traction it
it's really weird because it's a little
bit of an art and a science I I can't
really say like this is the exact number
but for sure just like Maria had with
scent bird you're like a hundred and
five orders we are onto something so the
first little seed of traction is almost
approved to yourself that you are on to
something
and then the next seed is about like
proving it to others once you're in YC
we usually kind of ask you well we
usually kind of push you to say if
you're growing 10% week over week that's
really good because that means that you
know you have the traction and then
exponential growth it's very hard to do
in your head but pretty much by the in
the batch will we have grown 10x if you
do 10% week over week so that's usually
something that is like okay we'll keep
on pushing that and if you can get to
that that thing then you're like oh yeah
and for other investors say well if you
want to go more that's really good but
don't person it's pretty good
in terms of within the batch so if
you're almost getting into that
inflection point it might be a good time
to to really figure out how to focus and
get to those that growth and that
product market fit which we could help
that YC yeah for consumer companies I
think there's - there's various types of
metrics in terms of growth that you can
focus on one is just user growth another
one is revenue growth just depending on
what you're doing so if you're building
a social app you you probably focus on
users versus if you're building an
e-commerce app you would obviously focus
and revenue more if they don't watch for
while you're growing if you're growing
really fast is to pair it with by
observing reach it's something like
retention and engagement - making sure
that you're growing the right types of
users or the right types of revenue
because if you're bringing on what I
call bad customers or bad users they're
going to turn if they turn right away or
they're just not good for the product
and you have to just fire them it's like
a waste of time almost and that growth
is kind of just a fake growth at the end
the day great um so as an engineer /
designer building a product between
prototype and beta what are the pros and
cons of launching before trying to raise
money
you should always launch before you
raise money but I don't yeah I think you
should launch that's great principle
well I think you could launch as soon as
possible in our industry we always say
you never know if you're polishing a
turd because you can be sitting there
and you can be like oh my god this is
the most beautiful thing and then you
launch it and you realize nobody can
find the signup button nobody even wants
to click on your setup but nobody even
wants to open up your email and then you
realize you have much bigger problems
than what you thought you were solving
so I'm a huge fan of trying to launch as
early as possible and even let's let's
say you know it's gonna take a while to
build there's certain things you can do
even before that you can start talking
to your customers you can start building
a wait list of things you can start
doing there's there's always things you
can be doing but the most important
thing is to launch as early and as often
yeah there's two ways to think about
this one is if you if if you don't watch
then you don't know if you have a
product anyone wants and why I raise
money for that like
where's the confidence in that like get
some come if you launched and you'll
have some confidence around that and
also there's a big difference in terms
of how much you can raise an evaluation
you can get if you have users and
revenue versus you if you have
absolutely nothing and so I think launch
now even if you're an engineer like if
Shopify is going to it's going to be the
fastest way to do it then just do it I
know some engineers are just like
they're just embarrassed that they have
to use Shopify to get it out there the
fastest but that's the thing to do all
right um question
a mother related question which falls
into the category of things that would
never be at a male oriented conference
if they are those but um how do you for
the folks who have kids how do you
factor in decisions to have children
with some of your your work goals and
your ambitions and your own careers it
was a popular question so I figured we'd
ask to get even though you know that can
be a tough one I never did factor it and
I just worked on YC then Paul and I got
married and had our son right away and
he just plowed right through it I never
sort of planned I wasn't very planful at
all which in hindsight is I wish and
sometimes I wish things were different
because the like as YC was growing and I
was working so hard to make it succeed
and it was so time-consuming that's when
I was having babies and like I barely
took any maternity leave I just worked
through the whole thing and maybe I
should have been a little bit more
planful but it's it's hard you know
don't put it off for too long be my
other advice yeah I would echo that I so
I came from a law firm before I was at Y
Combinator and I have nothing but sad
stories of colleagues who didn't have
children because they wanted to make
partner and it's just there's I just
don't have any happy stories from that
era I'm kind of like Jessica I just
thought life goes on and I'm having
children so I had children while I was
at a big law firm I do want to mention
we have a lot of great anecdote
about parents @yc and one of my
favorites is that we had a female
founder apply and she was at Y
Combinator for her interview and she
like ran out to go breastfeed her
newborn in the car and weeks at the pair
of course and she's great so anyway yeah
there's we have lots of stories like
that and I guess just I mean this kind
of sounds cliche but I kind of think
like you got to live your life and
there's tons of examples out there of
women who are having children and having
a startup and a startup is like a baby
so it's just like you have another baby
yeah so when I got married like five
months later I just I told my husband
I'm like basically I'm leaving to start
this startup and he's like what and I
think it's it's always it's a very
personal and tough decision as to
whether or not you want to have a kid
some people know right away and some
people don't and I knew this was
something that I had wanted and now I
can't take it back and no idea this fYI
you do you think about it it is a big
decision
sadly I will be honest I do think women
have to also think about a biological
clock for me personally it took longer
than we had expected and we we had like
there were just a lot more extra things
we had to do at the same time trying to
do this startup luckily my startup was
probably pre series like prime Series A
Series B but definitely by the time my
kid came around we were we're doing
quite well seriously but the whole
impact of even thinking about having a
kid honestly it impacts you almost when
you turn seven eight is just so young
but that's kind of thinking about this
thing I do think about this as much as
women and it's it's the there is the
reality of a biological clock but there
is also a lot of great things in science
we have some wonderful like we have
carat fertility that can help you you
know extend some of that and I think
like maybe me and Jessica and maybe even
care level we might have but I was
definitely considered I what is it
called geriatric pregnancy yes if you're
over 35 you're advanced maternal age yes
yeah we took my second one they were
like that gave me like this pin or
something I don't know it was terrible
but it is it is very much as for all the
parents out there it is the startup is
like having a kid it's so cool that you
did it with your husband I feel like I
had a kid without my husband so it feels
like I was having an affair all the time
like it's always Kabam Holly it always
comes first and like I'm sorry
so that it but if you can surround
yourself don't refuse help I mean it can
be done and there's many YC founders who
have done it at various stages all the
way from interview all the way to you
know when it's a lot larger Rashmi is
one of them she's gonna go do and are
yes so it's very plausible I there's
definitely some more tactical things if
you do end up hitting at that point
think about a plan when you leave the
like leave for temporarily definitely
have the communication I'm a huge fan of
keeping the communication lines open and
I'm only going to say this because this
came up with in the YC community your
options should vest on maternity leave I
was just shocked but it was there was a
whole discussion around that no really
somebody's option vesting suspended
during pregnancy they didn't suspend it
but the other founders had suggested
that they're like since you're going on
maternity leave we'd like to sit like
would you consider suspending your
options don't ya know that I've ever
we're gonna be illegal too so just one
more question and we've talked about
doing things that don't scale um if
you're doing things that don't scale
early on how do you convince an investor
or someone else that it eventually will
scale well you just need to have a
product plan in place and so anything
that's an investor should know at this
point especially if they're a tech
investor should know that something
repetitive software can can most likely
replace and so I think it's I think it's
usually good to have a little bit of
software to have automated some piece of
what it is that is not scaling and also
at every stage of growth there's a new
way of a different way of doing things
and so as long as you're in flicks
playing well in this stage I'm doing X
in this next stage I'll be doing Y and
in the future this is my plan for the
future but at least I have the next few
steps in place that's great advice thank
you very much YC as partners thank you
for coming
[Applause]
you